bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo à
bruxelles aujourd'hui un invité
exceptionnel
martin schulz le président du parlement
européen et cette semaine reportage en
tunisie où un projet de chaîne de télé
pour promouvoir la condition des femmes
dans les pays du printemps arabe a vu le
jour avec des soutiens européens mais
tout de suite avec martin schulz nous
allons évoquer les dossiers chauds qui
inquiète l'europe on commence bien sûr
par le cas chypriote
plus d'argent la plupart des
distributeurs de billets à chypre sont
vides l'activité des convoyeurs de fonds
a été suspendue conséquence du plan de
sauvetage européen accordé au pays en
échange de l'imposition d'une taxe sur
les dépôts bancaires
c'est sans doute injuste mais c'est une
solution mais alice
je suis venu retirer de l'argent mais
tous les retraits ont été bloqués la
situation est tragique
les milliards d'euros donnés par l'union
européenne ne règle pas les problèmes de
chiffres la population rejette le plan
de sauvetage et la proposition de taxer
les déposants ne passe pas dans le pays
ils veulent nous vider les poches c'est
le cri de colère de ce travailleur à la
mairie de nicosie il discute avec ses
salariés du plan de l'union européenne
qui a imposé une taxe sur les dépôts
bancaires
non je me sois juste l'union européenne
veut nous voler l'argent qu'on a mis
toute une vie a gagné
alors ce sont donc des témoignages de
chypriotes diffusée par toutes les
télévisions européennes avec nous sur ce
plateau martin schulz bonjour bonjour
vous êtes le président du parlement
européen vous êtes un homme fort de
l'europe parce que le parlement européen
compte de plus en plus dans les débats
européens et dans les décisions
européennes
une question tout de suite donc sur
chypre est-ce que selon vous chypre
pourrait quitter la zone euro non pas du
tout il faut qu'on garde la zone euro
ensemble ne faut pas sous-estimer la
volonté de quelques qui spécule qui
mettent leur argent sur les paris de
l'éclatement de la zone euro est un pays
important que l'autre les petits comme
les grands il faut garder l'union
monétaire ensemble parce que dit il
arrive une fois de séparer un pays d
autres ils vont continuer prochain cible
sera l'espagne le portugal l'italie et c
est ça nous coûte cher donc nous avons
un intérêt commun de regarder l'union
monétaire ensemble il faut pas mais on
fait comment parce que si les chypriotes
ne veulent pas de cette taxe sur les
comptes et si l'union européenne et en
particulier l'eurogroupe ne veut pas
payer la totalité de ce qu'il faut pour
chypre la situation est bloquée comme on
fait moi il faut trouver un sortie main
sortie qui inclut des éléments alain
côté je comprends absolument les gens
que nous avons vu ici qui sont en colère
on ne peut pas laisser payer les petits
genre les petits épargnants pour les
pertes et des grandes banques ça ne va
pas du tout c'était la raison pourquoi
il ya la directive adoptée ici au
parlement de garantie des dépôts jusqu'à
100000 euros à l'autre côté on comprend
les chypriotes qui ont des investisseurs
surtout russes mais aussi des autres
avec des grandes dépôt avec des taux
d'intérêt à leur profit qui est
incomparable plus haut qu'en france ou
en allemagne par exemple ces gens là à
partir des sceaux 1000 euros on peut les
imposer et
laisser les autres libre au dessous de
son âme il il faut que les chypriotes et
même trouve une solution pour contribuer
leurs 5 me à comment ils le font c'est à
eux mais imposer les riches plus que les
pauvres je crois ça c'est une question
de justice mais en fonctionnant
directement sur les comptes bancaires
est ce que un tabou n'a pas été levé oui
absolument
et dangereux si les gens oui absolument
si les gens ont l'impression que leur
argent sur les banques les plus sûres ça
c'est certainement pas très raisonnable
donc c'était pas la décision la plus
raisonnable comment vous dites vous
qualifieriez justement cette décision
qui a été prise ici à quelques jours à
bruxelles à 4 heures du matin à l'issue
d'une nuit très très compliqué comme
d'habitude chez nous c'est ce que le
parlement critiques moi je pratique
depuis toujours trop vite sous pression
à huis clos en pleine nuit avec pression
ça ne fonctionne jamais c'est une erreur
critique qui était fait alors ceux qui
en ce qui concerne le la garantie des
dépôts et la contribution il faut
trouver une solution qui protège les
petits entreprises les moins
d'entreprises les petits épargnants et
qui pèse
disons qu'ils mettent le poids de
contribution sur les épaules qui sont
plus forts vous vous le mettez à quel
niveau c'est à dire à 100 millions 25000
euros vingt-cinq mille euros c'est pas
moi d'en juger moi j'ai dit tout d'abord
le vingt cinq mille je crois qu'ils à
chypre à vingt cinq mille euros sur un
compte bancaire dans ce pays c'est le
maximum
mais comme l'un des hommes a dit celle
épargnons de l'épargné mondain toute une
vie ne peut pas l'imposer donc il faut
trouver une formule qui est très
chypriote qui est appropriée aux
circonstances très spécifique dans ce
pays mais une chose est claire nous
avons une directive européen pour la
garantie des dépôts il ne faut pas en
touche et donc pendant les jours qui
viennent il faut trouver une solution
qui compte en allant compter les
intérêts des chypriotes de garder leur
système financière mais à l'autre côté
on ne peut pas demander des
contribuables européens de équilibrer
les pertes des oligarques russes quand
vous avez appris justement cette
décision qui avait été prise qu est ce
que vous êtes dit là on fait une erreur
enfin sais pas vous mais qu'est-ce que
vous êtes dit je trouve que
l'eurogroupe a créé une situation qui
est un coup dur pas seulement contre le
rgo contre les institutions européennes
entièrement et pour la zone euro la
sommerau maintenant on n'est pas en
danger j'en suis sûr mais ça montre de
nouveau de nouveau nous avons une seule
des économies avec une avec harmonie
commun avec une banque centrale et 17
gouvernement qui décide à l'unanimité ça
ne fonctionne pas nous avons besoin
réformes en matière de systèmes de la
gouvernance économique en europe est ce
que vous craignez ce sera ma dernière
question sur chypre
à une contagion
ou est-ce que vous craignez déjà que
tout simplement la confiance du
consommateur de l'épargnant du déposant
européens soient remplies aujourd'hui
dix ans ainsi nous ne pourrions pas
l'erreur fait un pendant le big n est
pas seulement par leur groupe il faut
avouer que aussi le gouvernement
chypriote états membres de l'eurogroupe
s'est pas seulement les autres c'était
aussi les chypriotes qui ont insisté à
l'inclusion des petits épargnants
à à la contribution si on corrige ça
maintenant avec plus de justice sociale
et avec une contribution de super cheap
aux 17 milliards qui est fiable on va
sortir très vite de cette irritation
mais j'espère que ça aura lieu sinon si
on n'arrive pas à si on si on n'arrive
pas on est certain nombre de turbulences
je crois des marchés financiers
attendent que la sommerau agi cohérent
alors il ya un deuxième dossier qui
évidemment intéresse beaucoup ici au
niveau européen c'est celui de la syrie
a eu un sommet européen il ya quelques
jours ici à bruxelles et la france avec
françois hollande et la grande bretagne
a dit david cameron ont demandé la levée
de l'embargo sur les armes pour les
rebelles je vous propose de regarder ce
reportage est ensuite votre opinion
regarder
et voici la question syrienne qui
s'impose au menu du sommet européen le
dossier n'est pas à l'ordre du jour mais
quelques heures avant l'ouverture des
discussions paris fait une annonce
position que nous avons prise avec
françois hollande c'est de demander la
levée de l'embargo sur les armes dès son
arrivée au conseil françois hollande
confirme la position française la france
considère aujourd'hui
en syrie des armes sont livrés mais au
régime de bachar al assad et notamment
par les russes de nous souhaitons que
les européens lève l'embargo
l'initiative prend de court les
partenaires européens et le premier
ministre britannique david cameron est
sur la même position volontaire de la
première heure en libye paris et londres
où prennent leur responsabilité
11 françois hollande et moi-même nous
sommes d'accord pour lever l'embargo sur
les armes en syrie parce que cette
mesure j'ai un traité de la même manière
le régime syrien et l'opposition
seule la slovénie soutient la position
franco britannique la plupart des
partenaires allemagne en tête redoutent
que les armes ne tombent dans de
mauvaises mains si l'armement des
rebelles venaient d'une coalition plus
large de pays et qu'il gagne en
technologie cela pourrait je pense
rendre la situation encore plus instable
et surtout une fois que le régime
d'assad sera tombée ces armes se
répandrait dans le moyen-orient au sens
large et toute la région en serait
encore plus vite arisée est déstabilisé
depuis deux ans le conflit syrien passé
de la révolte à la guerre civile contre
le régime de bachar el-assad aurait fait
plus de soixante dix mille morts et plus
d'un million de réfugiés
alors martin schulz est ce que vous
comprenez ce changement de position de
la france en particulier
j'ai envie de vous dire mais quelle
mouche lequel mouche à quitte à piquer
la france
je comprends très bien la
les propositions françaises pour le
débat je ne suis pas moi moi même je
suis réticent en ce qui concerne la
levée de l'embargo
parce que la coalition de l'opposition
et très incohérent et parmi eux il ya
aussi des forces avec lesquels il ne
peut pas coopérer on l'a vu ça les
islamistes les intégristes on a vu ça en
libye comment ça se passe finalement à
l'autre côté derrière les propositions
françaises il y avait la pensée qu'il
faut augmenter la pression maximale sur
bachar al assad pour le montrer à long
terme tu n'as pas de chance et je crois
que ça c'est aussi un motif derrière ces
propositions françaises mais vous êtes
quand même opposé clairement à la lever
l'embargo je ne suis pas opposé du
premier moment moi j'ai pris ça aussi
avec une certaine surprise que le monde
érosion et françois hollande l'a proposé
à l'autre côté je le comprends encore
une fois il faut qu'on augmente la
pression et une annonce manquant les v
potentiel de l'embargo des armes
pourrait renforcer l'opposition c'est un
signal fort à bachar al assad de dégager
de bouger dans toute façon
donc la proposition était une
proposition qui a animé un débat
politique qui je trouve nécessaire mais
est ce que comme le dit françois
hollande le pire enfin le risque le plus
important ça serait de ne rien faire et
laisser faire mais là elle a tout à fait
raison encore une fois
cette double annonce est un message pour
assad mais à l'autre côté un message
aussi pour l'opposition il ya la france
et la grande bretagne qui proposent la
lgv et il ya les autres qui sont
réticents et ça ouvre aussi un créneau
pour un débat au sein de l'opposition
pourquoi les autres sont réticents et
peut-être ça mène aussi une
clarification à l'intérieur de
l'opposition de se débarrasser de ces
éléments qui ne contribue pas à la
libération de pays qui veulent remplacer
un système autoritaire par un autre pour
lever l'embargo sur les armes il faut
l'unanimité des états européens vous
croyez qu'il va y avoir un accord
j'espère toujours qu'il y à un accord
les préconditions je viens de les
détruire c'est une clarification au sein
aussi de l'opposition on peut augmenter
la pression à l'opposition de se libérer
de ses forces qui sont pas du tout
démocratique et je crois le signalait si
ça aura lieu il ya peut-être aussi une
possibilité pour nous on les vit de
l'ontario en fait l'embargo pour
l'instant ça tient jusqu'au 31 mai
si la france et la grande-bretagne
décide unilatéralement de livrer des
armes aux rebelles syriens vous trouvez
que c'est un prêt c'est vous trouverez
que c'est un précédent dangereux
c'est certainement pas sur le précédent
c'est peut-être il n'est pas dangereux
soyons honnêtes la politique extérieure
la politique de sécurité de l'union
européenne
et sous développés nous avons vu je
reviens à lire à la libye que l'union
européenne au conseil de sécurité a voté
dans les trois différentes directions
les impôts les autres contre les
allemands abstentions alors c'est pas un
précédent c'est malheureusement le cas
que des européens ont du mal de trouver
là des positions communes donc si je
résume bien votre position vous êtes
très prudent sur la levée de cet embargo
plutôt contre mais si ça venait à se
faire même uniquement la grande bretagne
à la france ça ne serait pas si grave
que ça
c'est une certaine normalité que les
deux états membres de l'union européenne
qui sont en même temps des forces veto
du conseil de sécurité agisse des temps
en temps un indépendante mans je ne
souhaite pas ça mais je suis réaliste je
prends note de la réalité merci beaucoup
martine chose d'avoir répondu à nos
questions on va maintenant partir de
l'autre côté de la méditerranée dans un
instant kathia gilder et son invité mais
tout de suite donc direction tunis avec
un projet de chaîne de télévision pour
les femmes qui est soutenu par l'union
européenne reportage à tunis signé ahmed
tazir
remontés à bloc faiza majri cette
journaliste nous emmène pour une balade
dans le souk de tunis est ce que nous en
tunisie actuellement on a peur elle
interpelle le badaud interdit aux non
musulmans
mais ça n'a pas de sens et questionne
les fille qu'elle croise
garder les filles comme elles sont
jolies regardez les filles de mon pays
vous êtes magnifique vous autres de
toute beauté les filles est ce que vous
sentez qu'il ya un problème dans le pays
oui oui et du problème quel est le
problème est ce que vous vous faites
agresser quand vous êtes dans la paix
on n'en est pas encore à ce stade
est ce que vous avez peur
je voulais dire on n'en est pas encore à
ce stade mais on a dû quand même des
changements au niveau vestimentaire plus
de femmes voilées
arrêtons de dire que nous sommes
au bord de la crise on va finir nous au
bord de la crise de nerf d'avoir une
fausse image de nous là où vous être
ce jour là des centaines de femmes
battent le pavé
l'ancien président bourguiba avait
accordé à statut des plus progressistes
aux femmes tunisiennes le plus abouti du
monde arabe ces femmes ne veulent pas
que ces actes qu'ils soient remis en
cause par les islamistes pas plus loin
qui hier a ni même à d les femmes sont
des manifestations pour sortir nu et
dans la rue donc rien que voir ça qui me
gêne c'est quoi la suite
à la situation quand toute révolution
c'est une situation ambiguë ça ne vient
que de démarrer tout le monde se
recherchent une opposition qui cherche
sa voie
palais présidentiel de carthage le chef
de l'état moncef marzouki célèbre la
journée internationale de la femme et
quand on lui demande si les acquis de la
tunisienne sont menacés aujourd'hui le
président s'énerve c'est de la foutaise
pure et simple jamais jamais les droits
de la femme n'ont été aussi respectés
jamais ils n'ont été aussi peu menacée
c'est tout simplement les gens qui
crient au loup au loup au loup alors que
le lot n'existe que dans leurs fantasmes
je peux vous assurer une chose que sait
ça relève de dénigrement et que ça
relève tout simplement de la mauvaise
foi ces gens là je leur dit et je le
redis taisez vous
la femme justement l'objet d'une
conférence dans un hôtel huppé de la
capitale je voudrais à présent vous
présenter brièvement le projet nice
atterri lille à le faire et
correspondant à bruxelles pour plusieurs
médias internationaux
elle a convié ses amis une ministre
finlandaise une députée européenne entre
autres elle est venue annoncer le
lancement dans un an de la première
chaîne de télévision dédiée aux femmes
du bassin méditerranéen
un pont jeté entre les deux rives
inès ayala sender est espagnol et député
européen elle en est convaincu le projet
ni sa tv peut être financée grâce à
l'aide d'une fondation européenne pour
la démocratie pour le moment on partira
au tour de entre 12 et 14 millions
d'euros essayer vraiment d'aller vers
les journalistes vers ces initiatives et
nissa tv je trouve que entre autres font
ça peut être justement un des ces
instruments dans nous voulons pour ce
genre de fondation si notre député est
optimiste laura baeza l'est beaucoup
moins elle représente l'union européenne
en tunisie en période de crise pas sûr
que l'europe ait les moyens de financer
une télévision pour l'instant elle a le
support politique de l'union européenne
à un très haut niveau
le
trio ça veut dire madame ashton l'a pas
du leem budgétaire qui est pas ou qui
ont été décidées pour les atv pas en
europe et à la démocratie pas encore y'a
rien
non
ni sa tv aurait pourtant beaucoup à
raconter si elle avait existé la
télévision aurait certainement braqué
ses caméras vers le théâtre el hamra et
son spectacle monstre anna moon ce
désenchantement après la révolution la
femme et son rêve voilée
voilà pour ce sujet signé ahmed tazir
est réalisé à tunis et nous sommes
revenus à bruxelles nous sommes avec
lila lefebvre bonjour je vous remercie
d'être avec nous vous êtes le pilote si
je puis dire de ce projet la directrice
du projet ni sa tv alors cette chaîne
vous avez fait une conférence de presse
ici à peu près un an avec des députés
européens le projet a avancé depuis nice
atv d'abord qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
est qu'elle est la vocation de cette
chaîne que vous voulez faire naître
alors comme son nom l'indiqué ni cela
veut dire femmes au pluriel en français
oui même en anglais et c'est une chaîne
de télévision qui sera dédié totalement
aux femmes euro méditerranéenne il faut
dire que l'offre des chaînes aujourd'hui
des deux côtés de la méditerranée et
rive nord comme rive sud elles sont soit
superficielles ou alors archaïque donc
c'est un projet innovant c'est un projet
d'envergure sans précédent
la deuxième raison aussi pour laquelle
un jour je me suis réveillé et lever le
matin je me suis dit ah tiens pourquoi
pas une chaîne de télévision dédiée aux
femmes parce que tout simplement on n'en
parle pas il ya trop de stéréotypes de
part et d'autre de la méditerranée
et donc c'est une chaîne qui serait
dédié spécifiquement aux femmes qui vise
à promouvoir la condition féminine mais
aussi peut-être les valeurs de la
démocratie dans ces pays qui ont connu
un printemps arabe qui aujourd'hui peut
être remis en question c'est ça le but
du projet aussi nice et tv n'est pas une
chaîne
destinée aux pays du printemps arabe ça
il faut absolument que ce soit clair
c'est une chaîne de télévision et la
zone européenne et européennes et
méditerranéennes pays visés vous en
particulier
ni l'ancien président français a appelé
l'upm donc l'union de la méditerranée
c'est englobe 4 43 pays donc de la rive
sud et est de la méditerranée plus les
27 pays y compris la nôtre mais elles
font pris la turquie oui forcément
alors on voit vous avez des soutiens
politiques notamment celui de madame
catherine ashton la haute représentante
et hurley pour la diplomatie européenne
mais est-ce que vous avez l'argent
aujourd'hui ce que vous avez une ex de
la guerre le nerf de la guerre les
musées romancier nous avons en fait des
promesses vous savez que vous évoquez à
l'instant café ashton elle a été à
l'initiative de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui le fonds européen pour la
démocratie
je pense que c'est un instrument qui
cadre très bien avec notre projet on
attend donc de recevoir un soutien il
existe fonds pour la démocratie il ya
des civils a été pensé par café
l'acheter en 2011 donc aux lendemains
des printemps arabes aujourd'hui il est
devenu une réalité et nous espérons nous
aspirons à recevoir donc un soutien
financier de l'union européenne aussi
autre chose de très important mais c'est
tv est ouverte à aux investissements
privés qu'on public de part et d'autre
de la méditerranée donc ça n'est pas une
chaîne européenne financièrement comme
on a essayé de le dire lors de la
conférence à tunis
les 7 et 8 mars dernier mais nous sommes
ouverts donc aux investissements arabes
aux investissements sud méditerranéen
mais aussi de l'europe de l'europe met
alors en même temps l'europe est en
crise on le sait on le dit on ne fait
que de le dire dans cette émission elle
n'a pas d'argent les discussions pour le
sur le budget européen se sont toujours
en train de suivre leurs cours dans dans
la peine ya beaucoup de programmes qui
voient leur fonte réduit ce que vous
n'êtes pas est ce que vous n'avez pas d
inquiétude qu'est ce qui vous fait
penser que les européens vont
privilégier votre projet qui sur le
papier est très beau effectivement mais
qui selon peut penser qu'ils vont
privilégier votre projet plutôt qu'un
autre
très bonne question il faut aussi en
période de crise effectivement il faut
aussi en même temps que l'union
européenne et les moyens de sa politique
vous savez ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
la nouvelle politique européenne de
voisinage
qui est pour moi une sorte
d'investissement si on parle que du sud
de la méditerranée
elle s'était engagée à
réaliser des investissements dans cette
région là du monde ça vous dit
absolument engager de soutenir toute une
série de programmes notamment sur le
plan économique mais pas seulement sur
le plan de la démocratie
vous le savez est sûre elle compte
maintenant énormément sur la société
civile de pays du sud des pays du
printemps arabe et donc j'imagine
qu'elle va tenir assez assez assez
promesses en revenant dans l'un des pays
berceau du printemps arabe la tunisie
nous avons interrogé la vice présidente
de l'assemblée nationale tunisienne qui
s'exprime notamment sur la question du
voile écouter ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle
dit
j'ai côtoyé tellement de femmes
habillées de tellement de façons sari
boubou foulard je cours du plan ou il
s'agit pas de la longueur de la jupe ou
bien de la couleur de fichu sur la tête
il s'agit de ce que nous portons comme
idée ce que nous faisons comme action et
comment on se voit dont la société dont
la famille comme actrice
alors lille est-ce que vous pensez que
nous même de ce côté ci de la
méditerranée avant un regard voilé si je
puis dire sur la femme l'image de la
femme méditerranéenne
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
stéréotypes ya beaucoup de craintes et
justement un des rôles de nissa tv
serait de transformer cette crainte
irraisonnée en une curiosité ce n est
pour aller dans les extrêmes
très souvent les gens du nord pense que
la femme du sud c'est la femme qui
portait un niqab et qui est interdite de
conduire une voiture et les gens du sud
pensent que la femme du nord elle est en
string et elle pose sur un capot de
voiture string d'un côté le voile de
l'autre c'est contre ce genre de
stéréotypes que vous voulez
lutter notamment aller votre chaîne mais
ce que vous êtes prête dans votre futur
rédaction si elle voit le jour
d'accepter que des femmes voilées
puissent travailler avec vous bah oui a
pas d'exclusion elle est où elle sera
ouverte à tout pour cela que le voile si
vous voyez bien madame bâ dit je pense
madame bandits qui est une femme voilée
mais vraiment le sentiment d'être une
féministe donc il faut arrêter ces
jugements il faut arrêter de juger avant
de savoir il ya des on n'exclut personne
la femme voilée la femme dévoilée la
femme noire la femme blanche la femme
musulmane la femme chrétienne la femme
laïque la femme athée toutes les femmes
seront donc mises en avant dans les
chats tv alors on voit qu'en tunisie en
égypte dans des pays comme ça la
condition de la ddt de la famille est un
peu mise en cause quand est ce que vous
même vous vous inquiéter
pour le respect des droits de la femme
notamment dans ces pays là vous êtes
inquiète tout le monde il faut il faut
être là justement pour montrer et pour
dire que les droits de la femme au même
titre que les droits de l'homme l'homme
avec un petit h doivent aussi être
respectées oui on est un petit peu
inquiet mais nous journalistes d'abord
on est là aussi pour le dire très haut
et pour le montrer donc avec ce projet
dit sa tv ce sera aussi une priorité
pour l'emploi pour la formation
absolument lycée tv ou chiche et 1 c'est
un projet économique on va créer de
l'emploi de part et d'autre de la
méditerranée
oui et bien très bien merci d'avoir nous
avoir expliqué ce projet ni sa tv qu'on
va suivre en vous souhaitant bonne
chance merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous il a le verbe et moi je vous donne
rendez vous la semaine prochaine ici
même à bruxelles au coeur du parlement
européen avec françois vos données pour
une nouvelle émission d'europe hebdo
très bonne site de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires va être